it is about time to face the fact that
there is something very very wrong in
the way physic treats time physics says
the following we are now in London uh
there is Jerusalem there is Mexico City
they all coexist in space and what
physics wants us to believe and they
have good reason for that is that all
moments in time also coexist within the
four-dimensional space time this is a
very powerful
and it has a lot of Truth in it however
the most important aspect of time and
that is its flow is being constantly
denied by physics they say that it leads
to all kinds of paradoxes I think that
we should not be afraid of
them